[Music]
to users they can be given as balance
now same people between the public car
park outside of the civics means please
do not delay your evacuations identity
model means please do not return to the
building and some people constitute a
pod council start please also note this
would easily switch off your phone to
silent
yeah I think you sure yes as indicated
and this committee receives reports
three times a year so in appropriate
this year was about strategy for the
forthcoming year that this adverse of
factors the further the 1718 an actual
year so the report has just stepped out
it's how we've complied with the
statutory codes and if don't approach
over the course of the last year and
that included setting and the treasury
management policy statement which has
out of the five chapters of the treasury
management across the council and it's
complement that there's a set of
treasury management practices which we
also a comply with and there was a
traffic management strategy report which
was set and that started to 1789
actually approved by the council and
then we reported a consent that as well
so essentially yeah complied with all
the statutory standards in terms of what
what we're asked to do report back to
this committee in terms of the specifics
of our investment performance in 1718
and obviously they are effective and
some degree by external factors mainly
the basic fan of England base rate which
did go up midway through last year
and not 4.25% 2.5% sir obviously had
some moral implications in terms of the
the rights we could achieve through our
investments just as a bit of context we
are expecting rights potentially
Gaffigan and during the course of this
year the lightest indication since it
even an estimate or walked through it
was could see another rise in the bank
right from so again that forgotten or
point seven point five percent
potentially which could increase our
capacity to only slightly more interest
in terms of the overall announced we had
to invest it the graph in the report
sets out the amounts we had invested in
treasury management instruments which
essentially means either in cash
accounts or burn in society externally
deposits or in money market funds the
balance at the end of this year was
slightly lower than at the start of the
year that was purely because an amount
of money was moved from my investment
funds and into one of our current
accounts which
those are cash flight so although the
natural balance looks lower at the end
of the year that was really just as a
result of cash flow management but you
can see the actual e that the average
amount that was invested over the course
of the year has gone up from an average
of about seven million to eight and a
half million and that essentially
reflects the amount of money that the
council's holding it in its reserves and
balances which is mainly because we've
been putting in this might be where new
homes - monies and there's our balances
have been increasing slightly and we
haven't been drawing down significant
amounts although we have got managed
plans for sprouts or to use - living and
projects rather than of course in the
next few years so we wouldn't
necessarily expect to actually keep an
increasing but at the moment our cash
balances have have risen slightly from 7
million about 8 and a half in the amount
of interest we earned was just so as
just on the 33 thousand pounds of the
course of a year which is relatively in
line with what we had last year although
our balances increased slightly as a
result of the rights not increasing till
midway through the year the actual level
of their investments sorry interested we
earned was broadly comparable with what
we received in the prior year so
actually yeah the amount of interest we
and overall was broadly comparable with
what we earned in 1617 and then there's
another graph that just slightly
illustrates how the average writes and
subtract the Bank of England base rate
and the live alright it's not an exact
correlation that is a general trend that
one the base rate increases is usually
gradually increasing the rate that we
can achieve across our across the
interest we own on our various
investment and then I'd point you to
take all five point one which is the
potential indicators that we require to
report on basically sets out the amount
of capital expenditure occurs in the
prior year in our original budget and
then what we actually understand a
purpose expenditure that year ends
allowing for that five cents in subject
to or just at the moment the ratio
finance and costs to net revenue stream
and is not really that meaningful for us
as an authority because we don't have
any server borrowing so that would
usually be used to sort of measure the
leveraging of the council in terms of
the amount of foros but because we don't
have any borrowing it's actually shown
as a small negative number which
basically is just showing how much
interest we earned as a proportion of
our revenue budget so it's not yeah huge
Lisa meaningful for us as an authority
that one and it's the incremental impact
couple investment decisions again it
just shows that there's a slight
fluctuation in the amount of capital
expenditure we've incurred year and year
as a proportion of as a council tax we
raise but really the attractions are
quite minor and yellow onion so yeah the
in terms of resource implications we've
all to success aside a budget let's
start near to your
external advice are wearing a contract
with the lien Catholic services which
was a seven and a half thousand pounds a
year for that they provide and
specialist advice on our treasury
management strategy and and provide
advice on which sort of institutions we
would be recommended to place
investments widths in addition to that
as you'll be aware they do provide some
training device to members and two
offices during the course of the year so
I think that's all I was going to say
that if anyone has any questions I'm
happy to try not so I know you said that
the interest that we generated was
approximately in line well when you when
you already talking about figures of 30
to 35% be three thousand pounds down is
attempt central now while the interest
rate went up seven in theory we should
have got more interest can we assume
that the reason is fabulous because you
had flowed so much of this money to two
thousand cash flow scenario the
investments will potential cash but it
would have generated more income was
moving out but I think that that sort of
what looks like a significant recovery
rate is really just think
trying out a pocket specific basically
Dave the month so it's not really
reflective of the actual balances that
they can't cancel factory for Sudhir so
that's not the reason why the investment
income is not is not higher this year
than last year
the reason essentially is that the
average interest rate that would learn
wasn't really and is significantly
different from 1617 and so on
surprisingly when devices may actually
rocks most of the financial institutions
are making fire and pop their rights but
actually when when the base rate went up
in November a bit of a lion we didn't
quite parents for example didn't even
put their rates up by 0.25 percent
immediately so we didn't realize the
full benefit of those rates going up
immediately so I think when there's a
bit of downside movement it's sort of
realized immediately but actually when
it goes the other way it takes a bit of
time for the markets to reflect that any
interest in we can and so essentially
it's because the interest rates haven't
really been significantly higher than
average over the course of 1718 and then
round 16 17 but we still have 3,000
pounds in comparison with the previous
year well I think the lost is maybe not
the right word but and
compatibly we earned 3000 pounds less on
average it does obviously also depend on
the balance of where your money is
invested so again that's partly net
buyers sort of liquidity in cash flow
requirements so if we have we need money
in short-term accounts to get easy
access to it we won't burn twice as high
rate as if we but it'll like that's
likely long run and that's slightly
higher rate so the balance of where our
my name is the best obviousy does have
some impact on
you can Sussman I think the other things
very mind is that with our investment
strategy we have heard loud and clear
that the the appetite for risk is not
great and so obviously that is going to
have an impact on our our investments is
about privileged investment it's about
safety it's about security and it's
about liquidity you know you could argue
that the scenario that we could have
generated or money but equally there are
scenarios where the income of further 30
to 33 thousand could have been less with
fairly secure with the figures that
we've got and going forward because
there has been that the increase in base
rate there are indications that return
from this coming year
should we bet on thank you very much
thank you chairman have this may be a
question that might have been raised
before all may seem maybe a little bit
there's a sort of question but I'll ask
it anyway counsel was got true
humanitarian advisors which costs the
council seven half thousand a year and
it states in here that it's deemed to be
a good value
but the council was investments it's
very simple straightforward mainly to do
with various different bank accounts
with set interest rates even if the
council didn't have a have you got an
obligation to have a advisors can it do
so without having to pay for this advice
could it not have it's team we need to
see if it could internally sort of like
make decisions without having to make
this payment it is on the basis of
what's being stated to do with the
amount of interest earned we not to
another seven and a half hours not for
that figure is dropped you don't even
further
question is part of what I explode but
you you know we have part of the answer
dating that we do have this
responsibility to perform and report in
certain ways so there is the need for
that statutory advice also when you're
doing the investments you've got to have
the data to base those investment
decisions on and to some extent that
costs what it costs regardless of your
size and also there's no we said there's
an amount of training within that as
well for officers so with the statutory
responsibility with the access to the
data and with the training
although the quadratics it's a lot of
money relative to what
at the moment regrettably it is
necessary at this moment of time but it
but that cost could remain static and
thanks a lot base rate could change and
we've been raising significant
involvement without that sums thing
saying yeah yeah I just reached write
that and as I said that I don't think
the cost driver for that advice is
necessarily the complexity of our
investments a lot of it is the sort of
fixed cost which would be saying
regardless of what type or thoughts you
are and what type of complexity of
investments you have because we do as
you say have to ensure that we meet our
statutory obligations and we do have to
do you know take advice on the potable
creditworthiness of particular
institutions so if you want to invest in
and so we do need specialist advice
because we don't have a specialist
Treasury treasury management and person
within your authority which have that
level of them you know expertise to be
able to advise on that so I think in
terms of if you compare you know the
cost annually to what it would be to
have a specialist person in post for
example in those sort of terms I think
the value for money we get in terms of
having that specialist specialist advice
on call and the training and the class
would get throughout the year I would
argue that we do get value for money out
of 500 I think in addition as well as a
review committee we have before
and yes there was a fan sniffing
committee that we need as continue to
get professional appliances
Thank You councillor Stanley Thank You
chairman what's the advice that we've
been given is that coming from the same
papers as last year and also has that
cost gone up since years previous to 16
to 17 almost say we really cured the
contract last year the providers are in
essence the same people that and it's
basically and then spun up off from
capita soul in custard services worse
and previously part of the cap degree
but now they are set for company they're
completely independent so they've got no
times then but in essence it's broadly
the same such people that are providing
the advice and in terms of the cost the
last payment we did was that four or
five years ago and that was 6,000 pounds
per year so basically we have no the
inflationary objects throughout that
period so the deposit now it has been up
slightly but that's partly because of
them yeah it's been helpful at for for a
number of years and partly because the
complexity of the advice that has to be
delivered and have increased just as a
result of the increased batch of trees
or requirements so that partly reflects
the complexity need by sector providing
for talent
yeah some time ago Oh Thank You mr.
chairman
I think we can accept that the rate of
return is relevant and correct for the
element of risks of the capital that the
council wants to see but if you recall
at one of the previous meetings we found
that the change in interest rate hadn't
been picked up and monitored and we
actually had the higher amounts on the
lower rate of interest can I just ask in
the view of that now how regularly are
the rates reviewed yeah so you're right
in that and there was a particular
instance where the one of the bank rates
had increased a little usually we've
rely on the bank itself to notify us of
any changing right they for some reason
that hadn't been we haven't been
specifically notified and it hadn't been
picked up we have it as if it controls
in place to make sure we are regularly
checking up now and also we've
reiterated with the battery and
procedures for their notifying us as
well so I'm ready to be confident that
going forward that that's expressions
shouldn't a driver student of I spend
thank you but we are monitoring
ourselves not relying on the banks
because our yes we have got real okay
it's true thank you thank you mr. chair
questions recommendation is that counsel
and other person commits a results okay
members moving to item number which is a
review of the Constitution I thought we
had Angelo assistant director video
services attendance this is the next set
changes from the projecting the
recommendation piece
[Music]
thank you I make the coda planning
practice or planning method
good practice of planning matters has
been looked at by the working group and
for example on page seven point four a
recommendation came forward that to make
it easy to read maybe and index which
we've done I've made if I tried to make
the guide I've updated the guide so it's
easier to understand and it's it's just
a guidance for members so rather than
using for example the term festering
your discretion just basing it back to
its term that members understand by it's
a brutish termination and so forth just
to make it slightly easier for all
members to understand their role when
the planning committee and give them
guidance as to how to do of applications
so the amendments have been mainly
attract changes are there I'm just happy
to take any questions on that this has
been the code itself has been one pass
the Assistant Director for planning so
he's had to look at it and also it's
been said with the recommendations that
came from work who that's been afforded
to him as well but he's had no comments
on those amendments the other members
are under the responsibility of
functions is where with regards to the
poplar holders is to take up individual
names and just keep the roles there so
it should there be proper holders that
change around it was just safe how much
to keep amending at taking bets for
Council
so because the role goes with the post
itself rather the individual and then
finally just add to my dedication as as
members of where I'm the data protection
officer for the council and it is a
statue to roll on to the new legislation
so it's just been added to the
Constitution to be recognized that that
post is that
council short one for an agilent 7.18
trading desk waiting about that means
giving your planning menses if you have
not attended for the mandatory it's been
taken out and it requires people could
be sorry some place to put my how far
down so it's better on training elven
mr. chairman website with the system
that because cancer sure probably isn't
aware that through the standards
committee we no longer have mandatory
training as such it's a requirement
which it's being changed and it has been
through counseling just funny because it
doesn't seem strongly not the word
require that there's all no longer a
mandatory
okay that just a question of thank you
very much thank you members do not have
to do it change if it's just a
requirement there's no you cannot then
make the do it because how do you do
that if it's not monitoring
that's following on from penslar hazel
Sanofi there's still the sanction
there's their so it's a relation to the
Development Committee if you if you
haven't met the required your
requirement you're not able to
participate in the vocals so there is a
sanction still there that's found out
you know
well if members have attended their
training and you've taken partying I
don't see an issue with that it on the
next slide it says do endeavor to obtain
any specialist training session so we
don't for me for you to endeavor or the
Kazakh to endeavor all members to go to
these training sessions it's up to them
if they want to do it if they've done
one they do it then they won't get the
opportunity to vote in their sphere no
not to be computed I think these this is
in relation to any other already
training over and above what is required
or
[Music]
[Music]
3 18 8 1 2 7 air quality project project
that's been on for a while you might be
taken to November so it's just they're
floating 518 the housing allocation
policy you will notice dander that's
been on for a number of months taken
June obviously we're in July now I'm
told it should be coming out by the end
of this week banana waiting for it to be
verified by an independent specialist
and this has caused some delay because
unanticipated unavailability of the
specialist but I'm told it's gonna be
out bug into this way turn into 618 the
Environmental Health Service Plan which
is the annual one that you see every
year again this should have been for
June I have spoken to Martin and is
hopeful that will be issued by the end
of this week in crisis job then 718 an
economic growth plan in the last month
and everybody asked me was it coming
into the planning policy subcommittee
you should have paid work
you know and I see there is an item the
economy growth plan so it's there the
next you know maintaining the corporate
inclusion and equality policy and action
plan is to update it and that's jus for
September and then we finally number 918
suspension of parking charges on
Saturdays before Christmas just one
question what happens with the
connection with EU law regarding 3:18
when you're so time with leaving me here
what what's the position with those
rules and regulation at the current time
we remember the
until we leave be subject to their goals
and regulations and I think you know
that will go on
I'm sure it won't be an aunt elapsed
because of the various activity I think
it's Friends of the Earth with the
emergence of a bit continuous yeah sure
it's going to continue on
[Applause]
members the time that it was quite a
wide subject and if it was a bit more
specific detail cassadee
yeah mr. garrow's know about this mmm
dog ballon Marcus hop agreed that it
would be appropriate for the review
committee to look at the enforcement of
dog failing as he was reviewing his
himself and I think by now he would have
completed that and he thought it'd be a
good idea as a new committee doctor how
enforcement could be improved
[Music]
I don't know if Marcus is actually done
it but there's no reason why you
couldn't bring a report direct to the
committee the second one chairman if you
allow me to speak Development Committee
we made significant changes to the
committee a couple of years ago now
maybe even three its usual that review
committee looks at the situation post
change and ensures that everything is
running as the proposed or the expected
we haven't done that we should
[Music]
that would be messy toss
no reason why can't again aren't we
forgetting manam to a committee meeting
compliance and what we're trying to
review whether it's working whether it's
not working whether we do it's quite
simple German and when the proposal was
made there was a report and the report
set out why we need to make the changes
the issue is I have a team that has that
report being fulfilled by the changes
that have been made or has anything else
occurred as a result of the changes that
require yet still further review so
really we need to see what the suit
stipulated at the time and then work
from that
[Music]
I'll get Matthew Thomas to look at the
old report
your comments I believe her contract
runs out in two months time and I think
that's why this item is brought down
nicely I think the other thing to
explore here is it's a significant
contract for the cow so it's very
important when it's a statutory contract
we have to have a loan for like one
officer and when the contract was first
made
there wasn't a vision for degree of
change that we have had for the members
of staff so I think the contract needs
to be looked at before he's renewed
because the continuity hasn't been there
[Applause]
it's is that the appointments committee
with the one in the original amenities
I do I'm becoming to give your car these
could be anything or elevating to
temperature contrast the can't be a
ghost accounts or you went to council
the NASA time it went by the appointment
committee and then order to counter so I
proceeded to do an extension or
[Music]
[Music]
I'm there a few others cancer decision
well I had to look into it whether we
could get Ming but on here we have had
us services before you know there's no
reasoning by yeah I'm just the rail and
railway and Liverpool Street Station
it's nothing
the cancer probably do about it no but
it wasn't no we accepted that it was
just highlighted that it'd be a major
complaint in residents within the
district and really it has the council
should consider just one example their
plans are haven't totally be going on
what the future is for hours
yeah
[Music]
what do you think as it seems to be a
major complaint our isn't the gentleman
the printer was mother strategies for 72
to residents on their playthings belief
reality play out what they usually do
Thank You mr. chair I mean I'm aware of
the concern that's been expressed about
this but it isn't something for you
committee our job is to review decisions
made by the council not to become the
council itself if members feel that this
is of such significance that they should
be asked for a meeting you should really
counsel if does that not really a
committee and on with our is the suggest
that therefore that I don't know who put
this forward but I was suggested members
feel that strongly that there that is
the appropriate route for that concern I
mean knowing this concern all I'm saying
is that this is not the appropriate
forum for that cancer
update on possible pension that we start
from Center had to be possible just to
review that you see that possible
proposal plans for it
I think the ongoing problems with the
alternative site you know that produces
another form sort of profitable
arguments but I think that where we're
going with that because I think the
proposed replacement the fast road is
completely like to be unsuitable in
Saskatchewan and this obviously involves
another world for us he was making that
in regards planning of waste management
and stuff on it so we like you to get
contributions from Essex County Council
if we decide to follow this up I just
wondered where they were moving it to
there was everybody different plans it
was just like any location may be worth
asking County they've got any plans
because of my last busy there which was
some months ago
it was there is no long term in my view
strategy they were there was so many
factors Muddy Waters they weren't in a
position to really say where they were
coming until was a number of other
issues fell in place it was it really
was in there they actually I deferred or
where we used to have a course be
meeting moved into a six monthly meeting
and we'd call anything anything
developed as Neutrik meeting so they say
I haven't been for something they've
changed from that policy okay Jenny
Sharon thank you honey
chairman could we not just ask county
councillors pepto and then a briefing
note circulated this committee so we
actually can decide what we want to do
anything
silent Walsh is helping them with ways
to contact him direct very approachable
go
well I've gotta cancel my first then we
serve something I was considering
bringing up onto the work plan
previously I've been kind of slightly
mislaid with some of the information
about public service I think it's
something that needs to be looked at
this is relation to the booster all of
the payment chains of the council
offices
I was I was informed that that
alternative arrangements have been made
for people to make payments but I've had
a number of conversations with
individuals who've actually found that
the new policy in regard to what what
what the people are dealing with council
tax and suchlike
is that method of payment is actually
quite limited and there's been no
facility
I'm aware of that people who wish to
make a payment by cash has actually been
in sort of like that facility has been
made available to those people and
they've been told that they're either
have to pay by direct debit or car
payment
now I've had someone who's needed to be
driven who had moved into the area and
due to a violent partner who has no bank
account for the reasons of the
circumstances that she finds herself it
doesn't know people locally and when she
spoke to the people that will counsel
tank she was felt that the options that
she had was payment by the director
before which he can't do so she wanted
to pay by cash that she was selfish she
couldn't do that if she didn't make
payment she will be taken to call so are
you asking for it to be review I feel
because this is a matter that seems that
quite urgent for some people is that
they've been threatened with call
actions even though they are in a
position to make payment why we believe
tender that's that we need to review
what is being put in place as what I was
hold for people to make make payment for
counter taxi bondage a cetera instead it
it was a breed at the last meeting that
councilors short well it's going to come
back with a point for the committee
tomorrow tomorrow at 2 p.m. and I said
I've doing recording to your cell phones
at all and then you can distribute you
outside with my have I've got a meeting
with only reps and Ben's regarding these
matters I've had various meetings anyway
I'm at my permit as your pet Lee as well
and I will come back just to clarify
they campaign the post office - they
can't unless they've got a payment slip
and the council it's not issuing payment
slips out to people so therefore they
can't cash or check well just once to
point now I'm not going to some good
some recent forum but it's like one of
us is in some square lots of spare and
they manage to pay by cash in there what
the other post offices are doing fine
calm site good but obviously come
forward I think the sorry charity before
that's blown you yeah I said the reason
why I feel I'll bring this back again is
because there's people being threatened
with being taken to call over this I err
pain and staff at both other stars mix
of things yeah because
they should be I should be a lot more
information circulated to be which to
make payment by a proper legal because I
do have had no members actually ask many
questions sauce whichever line yeah that
he's that is correct there's only two
forms of payment and things one stroke
the bank the one you've got their bank
account to pay you so don't need don't
worry activity you can't pay into that
account and the other form is obviously
old mine in your car that's very
difficult at the moment because it does
ask you for your business account is it
that they do ask for business account
number not your cancer account number
unfortunately that's what I've had any
weight twice to payments on my committee
ashore and you can't just can you use
the PayPal
not the paper you know my limit point
paint like I need your cars but this is
another one I'm sorry a couple my hand
up like this another point I'm gonna
make up to tomorrow
as I inhale reach I can't paying it the
post office to be better carpet yep
tomato knife point Conway yeah alright
thank you
you can awesome as well right mrs. Mason
Thank You mr. Jim just to a sister
counselor sure the post office can only
accept payments they have playing it's
it's for the bank's if there is a
pioneer slit Southend Council for your
information provide their tenants that
wish to pay by cash we they eat looks
like credit cards not and they can go
into the post office with that our
council does not do that but the major
concern that I have is that residents
that want to pay cash if we don't accept
that payment we're causing the
difficulty we likely to they likely to
spend the money elsewhere we likely to
lose cash flow more than that is legal
tender can we as a council justify I
think this ought to come back to the
next we will have explain that I will be
putting paper out for you
but it's not just yourself I think we
need to ask our officers as well for
information because there's a lot of
mysteries I think we did agree that
we've been waiting front just give some
guidance
I'm gonna do that to the world i cherubs
having meeting with the reps of bone on
my pillow
tomorrow Jim Bob I'm concerned from what
I heard from Catholic Way and it's being
recorded
he said he will put me right if I've
ever misunderstood that residents are
being threatened with the cause if they
don't pay by the means that have been
put to them that's a very serious
allegation and I don't think it's one
that should sit and wait for reviews
from from from or to this committee I
think that it ought to be put to the
managing director and I think the moping
in the individual case that's know in
all cases is known and assurance given
whilst this committee is considering
whether to review it or not is that so
residents are given the appropriate
assurance because it's because it's on
the record it's being recorded and that
actually could end up being a policeman
[Music]
just come on to the online payment
there's personal nothing on here Lorne
our consul just do you think I'm here
I'm saying so much just to clarify just
to help you out you know another quick
probably my hands with oh yeah yeah I
mean I think these things are illegal
clarification not washing what is the
council legally obliged to to make
available in terms of means of payment
and we need to make sure that we are
correct within the law because another
another point is this is that council
tax demands are issued at the beginning
of April and on that on those council
tax demands its stated means a payment
since then the cash machines been
withdrawn now these are this is the
point contact the council has with its
residents by rather the council tax
demands if there's been no furthering
that information or that's been
circulated by the council and that
interchange of means of payment this is
what's causing difficulties because
people expecting to do to carry on in
the way that they've needed to be
carrying on now there's better change
and it happened and people are not being
informed about this and then again
behind on their payments and then
they're being threatened court action
yes I mean we we've established as the
show is going to have a meeting with him
tomorrow she will report back to us if
you don't think that he is going to take
the process there is nothing to stop you
I think viz with all or guys their plea
or going to the ad for grabs and
benefits and expressing your concerns
but okay
we've asked counselor sure to come back
to this group you're saying that what's
happening needs more urgent attention
than very cool
there's nothing view represented as a
vault counselor as far as I can see
that's why they're not the I sweep with
process it quicker or the idea is for
speaking through any thoughts of
actually it is a question of expediting
that's right and that's the best that's
my point
yeah but so this this matter was brought
before committee at the last nice meetin
it was discussed but you don't bring in
fresh information that we didn't have at
the last meeting no I didn't have that
information exactly at time so you know
so I'm I'm doing my best to update the
22 I don't make me understand your
difficulties out there and so the
counselor Shaw is aware of these
difficult all those other as what's been
pointed out we can we can take some more
immediate as it has individual counties
okay thank you very much of the future
basically it keeps sitting to be made in
November rather than have a cold in you
can get information
what just jiggle information early
Martin can go through was specifically a
bit like beef and in these eighty point
electric cars etc a parting on on the
strategy of all for sharing cars and
electric cars and and that sort of think
that's what he's future things what he's
looking at in the future that everybody
about electric cars and there was some
like on that sort of thing so I know
what these strategies how is he going
about it before this foreseeable future
particularly their quality as well and I
bet we take this outside the meeting
okay I'll arrange for you to meet with
Martin stop me and we'll discuss it and
then if there's still concerns that we
could bring back to the committee for my
tetanus